we kind of veered off this direction i
wanted to stop before and move into the
ramifications of
having a world worldview built upon you
can't succeed
because the world is the problem so one
of the one of the key things is like
core elements of the culture war one
side says you can do better
and you know find your path towards
victory the other side says
there is no path because the world is
bad and the world must change for you
yeah which brings me to this story from
the daily mail quote
it's like living in palestine
minneapolis is renamed
murderapolis as children under police
of under police city pay the price and
blood for violence
that has skyrocketed since the death of
george floyd
so they go on to mention 211 people have
suffered gunshot wounds up from 81 last
year
more than 200 cops have left or are
leaving signing off for on disability
more than 300 people uh gathered at the
site of ania's fatal shooting for a
peace walk a call from the community
to put down the guns and pick up the
love what's happening now is
i've i've experienced occupy wall street
i've experienced it with these activists
when you keep telling people over and
over again there's literally nothing you
can do to succeed
what happens people don't give up
believe it or not they don't succeed but
some people decide okay then then i'll
take
then you get crime you get violence then
they demand the system change
and you know we see a lot of these
stories about police brutality and and
police shootings
there's a story right now so in
minneapolis the other night they were
rioting why
because of an armed fugitive who was
arrested like 20 times and had multiple
felonies
us marshals tried to stop him they said
he drew a gun they shot and killed him
of course then they start rioting and
one guy is caught on camera
and they ask him what he's here for and
he says believe it or not i forgot the
guy's name he's like i'm not going to
lie i don't remember the guy's name
they clearly have no idea what they're
talking about the own
so so in a sense it's kind of sad they
don't
know why they're doing what they're
doing other than it's the only thing
they were told they could do to affect
change these are people who were never
told when they were younger
you got to keep trying until you figure
it out if if you're if you're trying to
find a path towards victory it's not
working try a new path these are people
who are told there isn't one
you will never succeed and so what do
they do they
they just go out and smash yeah exactly
i mean and that's a huge cause of crime
right people believing that there's
nothing they can do to improve their
material circumstances within the system
they have to break the rules in order to
get ahead
and so if your view of the world is that
the only way you're ever going to make
something of yourself or achieve any
level of
status is by hurting other people guess
what you're going to hurt other people
you're going to take their stuff
or just destroy things and burn it down
because because your body can't have it
no one have
no one can have it well you're just in
her you're hurting the insurance
companies you're not yeah exactly
i'm sorry i'm so glad insurance was
invented so we could just burn down
anything for any reason and no one gets
hurt
there's no victim people well i just
want to mention this about insurance
there are people
who have literally gone into debt
just cleaning up the debris from their
place of work or the business they own
being destroyed in a riot
and the insurance check didn't even
cover that so they went into debt
without even getting to reopen their
business
insurance will pay for let's not forget
you ever go to a pizza restaurant and
you see a picture of like the the owner
and he's
like tony danza and he's giving me a
thumbs up that photo's never coming back
you can't get insurance for that
photograph but let's let's be a little
less silly
less silly the first dollar everyone
frames their first dollar they put up on
the wall
yeah the first hour that comes in never
getting that back let's say the guy had
a painting from his mom on the wall
never getting that back let's say his
mom
died and the last thing she gave him
after she died was this beautiful
painting and he says i wanna i wanna see
this painting every day in my shop
and they threw a brick through his
window and they burned it down insurance
will never pay for that
exactly and also profit margins are very
thin so even if you're lucky enough to
have your insurance company pay for it
your rates are going to increase and
it's possible your rates will increase
so much that you're not going to afford
to operate in that area anymore so fewer
people are going to open shop
in that area the only people will be
able to afford to will be massive
businesses so you're just hurting the
little guy in the end
yeah this is this is what happens when
you know people are told throughout
their whole life
there is nothing and that's that's the
danger of this white privilege i
i ideology these leftists they talk
about white privilege like uh
we talked about this last week or
whatever when chris ruffo was challenged
by that guy mark lamont hill
because you know he was saying they're
trying to say whiteness is all bad and
then mark lamont hill is like i think
that was
it was mark might not think his name and
he's like tell me one good thing you
like about being white and chris roofer
was like i reject that framework
like as if race is the component and
he's right
that that dude who is interviewing him
views the world through
you by nature of being white have
something this is critical race theory
that whiteness is property that's that's
literally what they think they think
that you're walking around with like
plus two charisma
because you you started as a white
person racial passives
yeah exactly like as if you have like a
little book you open it up and it's like
white it means you get plus one all
stats and plus one money it's like it
doesn't work that way
it doesn't you have to be a good person
and it's the weirdest thing that
that they attribute it to white people
because imagine it this way let's say a
baby is born in the in the middle of the
woods and the mom dies
and then wolves come and and take the
baby and the baby's raised by wolves
is that baby going to have privilege no
it's not it's it's going to be living
with wolves and eating refuse
look it has that's the kind of argument
that somebody who doesn't
care about history or is intentionally
not
all right so i'm greek right my
great-grandparents were
having to deal with the ottoman empire
we don't
it's not a modern thing that a lot of
people talk about but they were
basically on the run
refugees some of my extended family back
then might have even been like slaves
who knows
and then they were on the run for many
years and eventually they made their way
to america whatever
that had nothing to do with race it was
just a terrible thing that happened to
a certain region of the world that there
were
bad people doing things to people who
were just trying to live their lives
kind of thing it's terrible
but i use the example of this like i'm
first generation american i was born
here
i had opportunities that my parents
didn't have that my grandparents
definitely didn't have like my grandma
was picking tobacco as a girl
you know she's telling me about like her
hands were brown because she's like she
was picking up all this tobacco
like a girl she didn't have a childhood
my grandpa same thing didn't finish
middle school i got to finish high
school
it's it's just a straight like i'm so it
drives me nuts to think like i didn't
realize this until i was a
an adult but just to have been born here
is such a lucky thing for me compared to
the rest of my family
just one generation ago my dad i i don't
want to talk too much about him out of
respect but like
he was born in like terrible conditions
and just the fact that he made it to
america at all
is such a freak accident and then for me
to have been born here is even more of a
freak accident
but then for me to go around and i can't
blame all right let's say my
career didn't work out until recently
whatever i can't blame anybody but
myself for that
i didn't work hard enough i didn't have
the right opportunities whatever maybe i
had bad luck
but i i i was born in america and that's
already not to disrespect anyone who
wasn't but like
just to be born here but in this time in
this time that's what's going on
it makes you so lucky because because
you realize if
if this if we were doing this show if we
were trying to do the show maybe like
seven years ago sheamus would be
surrounding me with a bunch of
with all his buddies pouring milkshakes
on my head and like laughing no it would
be the opposite dude the irish would be
getting made
no i mean it's true that like the irish
were extremely lower class
and i know that my grandfather on my
mom's side
was basically pulled out of school in
fourth grade so that was the highest
education ever gotten he just had to
work for the rest of his childhood in
america
yeah in america okay in america so
things and also i won't get too into
the details of my family history but a
lot of really horrible
horrible circumstances that just befell
my uh
pretty recent ancestors even in this
nation this is an incredible time to be
alive and also when i look at where my
ancestors were just one or two
generations ago
and where i am now it's really
incredible that people could work their
way up any kind of hierarchy that
quickly over time
because in many other countries you just
have a kind of caste system
and people look at the united states and
they say well there is a hierarchy and
so that must mean you have kind of a
caste system the richer at the top poor
at the bottom
but what people don't recognize is that
there is so much
there is so much moving in and out of
income brackets in the united states
that is entirely unprecedented
historically and also in the world today
there's more economic
mobility in the united states than any
other country in the world but
you will never be told you're only told
about income inequality you're not told
about the fact
that people move through their income
bracket extremely fluidly in the united
states and that just
isn't the case to the same extent in
other developed countries and even our
low income brackets like the fact that
we have like air conditioning in our
houses that you could pay for an air
conditioner or whatever
that you can go and buy groceries half
the world can't buy groceries half the
time
the fact that you can buy a crappy car
let's even say like that just kind of
runs like puts you already ahead of so
many people yeah
we have we have fat homeless people i
mean
like we've got what's right well yes but
in homelessness also often and i know
a number of people are homeless and it's
horrible but oftentimes homelessness
is a product of mental illness or
alcoholism it's not as if we don't have
enough resources for everybody and
you you also have that uh video um i
tweeted this video out from
uh twitter account on the venice
boardwalk it's three guys just laughing
about how they love
being homeless uh so i worked at a
homeless shelter one of the biggest
problems is people don't
we we get this so often from the left
when they're like we could end the
homelessness if we just stop spending
money here i'm like bro you can't
you can't it's it's like children
and i mean this with respect you know
children just lack knowledge they
they're they're young they haven't
experienced things they also lack wisdom
and
it's not absolute there are a lot of
really smart and wise young people for
sure
but they look at homeless people and
they're like we could just pay to end
this and i'm like go
down to venice and ask the beach bums
and they're gonna be like i'm not going
anywhere
they're back i like living out here dude
i gotta admit like venice is rad
they got public showers that are
beautiful and tons of people just sleep
on the beach
you can't convince them to stop doing it
because it's the it's their passion they
love it
and it's true for other places too
they're they're they're rail rail
jumpers
that whatever they call these people
they ride the rails they ride cargo
trains throughout the united states
and they have you know it's like it's
like that trope of the the hobo with the
stick
and it's got the handkerchief wrapped in
the back and it's full of stuff not like
that specifically
but i knew a ton of people when i lived
in seattle they were they were rail
jumpers
they would wait for a cargo freight
train and they would jump on the back
and ride it for free across the u.s
sometimes the train would stop and the
engineers would get out start beating
the crap out of them and chase them off
typically they would just ride for free
across the us they don't want to to not
be homeless
so the solutions to these problems are
not particularly easy and people have to
realize
a lot of it comes down to personal
responsibility and personal choice
well i also want to say this i want to
be really careful here too because there
are a lot of homeless people and i know
homeless people who don't want to be
homeless they wish they had a house and
i see this in the city i live in i also
see this in the chicago area tim i'm
sure you saw this when you were working
at a homeless shelter was it in the
chicago area no no
so obviously there different parts of
the world have different problems with
homelessness but
in chicago where it's freezing out i
mean a lot of those people they really
wish they had a home and they don't
but that's not necessarily a product of
the fact
that there weren't enough resources for
everyone i mean we have multiple empty
homes for every homeless person
it's also that a lot of these people are
really seriously mentally ill
right or have a very serious addiction
problem and just putting them in a house
is not a solution to that problem they
have to be monitored people need to be
taking care of them
or they need to be in a mental health
facility somewhere so there's more that
we have to be doing for these people but
it's often made out to be this
this problem we could solve by just
throwing enough money at the right
people or just placing them in these
empty houses that are already there and
it's totally naive
once again like i say children you know
people who have never owned a home yeah
or been responsible for a home so look
two days ago the the a lot this fire
alarm went off
and so everybody has to get up fire
apartment comes we leave we leave the
house
so lightning struck the other day and
our internet broke so something
happened we don't this was this was you
know after the outage but
something happened that may have fried
some electrical circuit we don't know
there was a storm before this
and so when the smoke alarm went off we
were worried there may have been
something
internally some wiring that tripped it
we couldn't
i swept the house couldn't find anything
and we're like what are we supposed to
do
so we call them they come did a sweep
turns out we're good hopefully we're
good
maybe it wasn't lightning that struck it
maybe there was an electrical fire on
one of these cables or something
that we didn't realize and that's what
made the alarm go off maybe it wasn't
lightning i don't know
but i i recognize that having to
maintain this house and having to be
responsible for people's safety
now imagine you took a homeless person
and just put them in this building and
said it's an empty house there you go
the alarm goes off let's say this
person's not mentally capable of taking
care of the house
and then the house burns down and
they're in it no one calls the 9-1-1 no
one's there for him
you can't just put a person in a house
it doesn't work that way exactly
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you